hey guys hope you guys are doing well
welcome to my channel my name's Alex our
and the Muslims those who know me know
me those who don't know me such as
non-muslims might be tuned in to his
channel do check the hell out get to
know Islam educate yourself not about
hearsay he stays CNN BBC brainwashing
Islamophobic websites and channels
because when you go down that route
what happens is you fall into what Ricky
fell into unfortunately is misinformed
ill-informed not informed are they not
informed and misinformed as offenses but
it doesn't matter let's move on so you
will get such in the middle school with
such hate and there's something that
they claim we as Muslims have something
called Isis but I think it's the other
way around I think such individuals who
go to summer phobic videos and use Isis
have something in common both Isis and
themself believe it sounds about
terrorism and promoting violence
now we're gonna discuss that further who
is Richard why is we just talk a degree
why is it so upset
who's making them upset well let's go
through that but then understand why did
Richard do what he did you know what
made him come and walk is bad in such a
way and also how would they feel if
somebody did the things about him or his
friend and took him out on death and
cherry-picks and major theme is evil or
made them look evil well I think that's
what my research shows that actually
happened to Richard so before we go into
a witness background let's find out the
conflict that he had between him and
another atheist you to box let's go into
that firstly you're bending the truth so
you can slander me and they also did
this to freelee the banana girl later on
in this video
they took a clip of her out of context
so they can slander her so they can keep
playing victim games you guys hear that
they took a little out of context of
Richard splint out of context 50 not
forget that was one and then we also
have freely said I'm gonna start with so
uh she's probably my least favorite
that's because she's a mean person
they're all kind of Shaffer guys so I
just wake up and I'm thinking about
something in bed which I think that
quite often and that's where the people
who continue to eat means area even
though they know the impact of their
diet choices on the planet on the
animals that watch the Earthlings they
know the fact that being educated for
they
to continue eating animal products
whether they actually deserve to
continue living with this is Rich's
friend who have said I don't even know
if these individuals who currently is an
animal know what they go through she
deserve to live that right there is out
of context right okay good now my riches
is coming back that up and say you know
what hold on a second she didn't mean
that
let's see what was it says to the false
claim that his friend the lady is going
to yeah again they cherry picked that
quote they chose exact quote out of
context out of context to make her look
bad to make a look but listen if you
actually watch freelee's entire video it
was the entire video
she didn't suggest that at all she
didn't suggest that us all okay
she was just trying to make a point that
your lives aren't the only lives that
matter and you can't just use I don't
care as an excuse fair enough fair
enough
whisking in the chomp explain yourself
as you can say I'm really passionate
about this and do I want to kill people
no I don't want to kill people and yet I
was in that situation okay now we have
the full context so you're both in liars
now this really unglued on the angle of
those students fall lying you just
picked a few vegan channels who aren't
complacent and who are willing to
criticize your unethical lifestyle that
was just justifying why she said that
and since you can't come up with any
sound logical arguments against us
you're using emotions and your feelings
as an argument you combine any solid
obvious against us and you use the
emotions brothers and sisters and
difference please let's listen carefully
you're using slave morality as an
argument and you're cherry-picking
quotes and taking them out of context
show picking clothes I'm taking them out
of context riches in order to slander us
and paint yourselves as victims great
let's pause for a moment now I have a
challenge and that challenge is going to
come I bender the video now before that
challenge comes
did you hear the words that he was
saying to defend his his friend means
grounded now which is I am NOT doing the
exact same thing with Islam
you can be statistics and in the verses
of the Quran apparently says kill them
wherever you find it as a job and give
up context cherry-picking lying
slandering I'm sure not doing the same
thing with the sandwiches yes you are
aren't you
so is it not hypocritical is it not
unfair let's cut that you defend your
friend and come and say hey this is what
she meant and you subject against your
lion is you taking about context and
you're doing exactly the same thing that
she is doing with her friends against
you and your friend towards Islam you're
doing exactly the same thing wicked
wicked isn't that sad isn't that sad and
you know and I luckily before I could
come here insulting news very Iraqi
youth and I have many evidences to do
that but I'm not going down that route
now let's get to know which it a bit
more what kind of person is he is he
what is he suffering from that may be
making and do these sudden right let it
anonymous I hate children they literally
make me sick when I see babies in a
commercial I start to gag and almost
throw up and I have to look away and
mute it and when I say babies in a
stroller especially when they're crying
I just want to put my first thing and
step on it
it tells nothing but blood and pop
placement now this next video is a video
of another youtuber we have seen to
Richard the guidance made the semaphore
this video recording his granddad having
a heart attack
and basically blaming him for eating
meat and that leads in time anyway
suppose we do right it will kept sending
me this video and I kept ignoring it but
until I finally clicked on I said fine
I'll watch this I was blown away at how
disgusting and vile this video really is
this is this is the type of video which
makes you sit back and say to yourself
is
this guy going to become a school
shooter and I just got back from the
funeral thing that we had it wasn't
exactly a funeral but a bunch of family
got together and I was dragged to it but
anyway I was planning on showing you
guys footage of my grandfather actually
having the heart attack as soon as the
paramedics got the house I took out my
camera and started filming but some a
bunch of people my family my mom my
grandmother uncles [ __ ] like that
they threw a bit fit about me showing
that footage on YouTube they're
perfectly fine with eating foods that
cause heart disease and makes people
actually die of heart attacks but when
it comes to actually showing people what
happens when they eat these foods that's
too much now so far exactly thinking
what on earth is going on right why is
that a concise fit in such a way
well let's find out what is the personal
the person behind this mentality why I
guess essentially I think the following
video will he was a bleep explanation
what we did is suffering from as some of
you might know reason we have had a
little bit of mental problems I've been
having hallucinations cuz lately I have
told you guys about my issues with
mental illness in the past with
hallucinations and [ __ ] and it's been
coming back I've been hearing voices in
my head I've been seeing writing on the
wall saying ha ha ha ha
kill yourself fight and not me doing
credit see that you say Menten suffer
from hallucinations and he sees writings
on the wall say ha ha ha from yourself
now this is not funny Mike I'm not gonna
laugh and I'm not going to book Richard
and do what he does to us by mocking our
villages and I will profit what I'm
going to do that he suffers from mental
illness and we hope he gets well so
we're going to wish the worst for him I
say ha ha one of them I'm walking about
with we hope you get well witches let's
move on let's carry on watching next
video that's not good I don't want to
you know go back to having like really
bad mental problems and I've also had
family members who've gotten into some
really serious problems with their
mental issues and schizophrenia so
but I did have another bit of a mental
breakdown just a few days ago I took a
few days off YouTube just to calm down
and relax and deal with it I was seeing
really bright flashes of color and
patterns and I was hearing this ton of
chatter and voices inside my head it was
like a hundred people were talking to me
at once
what was it was very scary very shocking
and to be honest it's something that you
would expect my wishes set and catch up
about is it Isis behavior you know and
you guys can watch it for yourself and
see and what you feel inside the servant
mess watch but uh yeah if I had the
opportunity I cure a sore throat with
this tonight really like to use this
knife on him like he really does deserve
to die like he tells me associate that I
mean just heard she'd just be killed
like love to just slide a knife right
across his throat and just watch him
like just look off scared when you know
he's just done now the reason I'm
talking about this is because I want
actually a public record so people can
actually see what he said here now when
I was that I was pretty shocked because
I'm trying to understand because we
shouldn't doing the videotape Isis this
and that killing people that are not
under sighs oh hold on a second and
you're doing the video where you're
saying you want to sit another person
spoke open I want to see them in fear
riches you are the same person and says
that you do not let your little so many
beliefs about these veganism and you
don't like to see another animal suffer
and how they slit have it broke the open
and you want that to another human being
another human being so now this next
video is about another youtuber who's a
piquant having a battle or a debate with
Richard because which it is not to be a
hardcore vegan or describe him extremist
position is vegan and he came for
animals however this guy seen Richard if
you care about animal so much why did
you go and buy a dog from a breeder in
another country Amsterdam Holland and
bought the dog flow and thrown into
Canada in a 12 hour journey in a little
cage and when the dog arrived they
actually
proving itself right so these basically
you need animal go fetus not only that
this guy is having to go ahead and say
look you have got the animal not only
that you are forced feeding the animal
Rican food so Jazmin admits that it
would have been stressful for the puppy
to be torn away from its family and then
flown over to Canada in a crate for 24
hours yeah Jasmine that was probably a
really stupid decision to make that dog
go through that ordeal we had our own
vegan kibble for about a week and a half
then I started cooking fresh meals with
supplements rice with vegetables etc
didn't work so there's been actually
having this pet dog and they've been
feeding it force-feed in it vegan food
rice and vegetables and don't have to
would be a diarrhea on computing
comfortable now in its time that is
animal cruelty that is animal food we're
going to come to animal right and if I'm
in a minute that there is animal cruelty
how is going to force feed an animal
something like just equality is not
justice just because you have a feed
vegan diet good I mean you haven't eaten
your vegetables and right no problem
however 14 in the animal that is animal
cruelty man dies after the animal is
created to eat meat
give it meat you know so it's wrong so
however this youtubers having a gotten
in etcetera etcetera now normally I'd be
laughing at this but she is serious they
actually gave the dog rice and
vegetables with vegan supplements it's
absolutely ridiculous that dogs can't
have grains yet you're feeding the dog
rice and vegetables so since when is
rice not a grain and it might have been
that the vegan diet made it worse in the
meantime she kept losing weight because
she kept having diarrhea she couldn't
eat anything she couldn't digest
anything nothing over the food worked so
we were like what the hell are we going
to give her now now God since we have an
idea who she is and what he suffers from
now I can CVC you know what okay I'm
going to do that I'm never going to
answer anything that you brought up
because you know what from these videos
and your behavior how you're behaving
and how you treat
somebody's somebody's broke recorded
your grandma has a heart attack etc etc
I should say you know you're absolutely
near fewer you are not recommend police
is a lie - because you don't senior okay
the ideological route
are steeped in outright lies and
dishonesty the Prophet Muhammad just
came up with some [ __ ] story to
control and manipulate ancient primitive
uneducated people through fear and
violence and this behavior is evident
with how Islam treats animals through
halal slaughter
yes the ideology of Islam itself which
is a horrible religion of hatred
violence bigotry and misogyny well we
should be afraid of Islam and here's why
why is that it started to spiders came
off of this believers that is a total
life because the Christians Muslims and
Jews live under one banner together what
kind of a me up Edmisten oh this is a
teaching which I'm going to on the
screen number we like this idea let's
see what rights our Prophet Mohammed
game to the non-believers the Christians
and the Jews when we would live in at in
Medina right okay let's go through yeah
okay in 628 see from behind and grab to
the childhood privileges to the month of
st. Catherine monastery and monks I know
okay
it was all this is a message from
Mohammed even Abdullah as a covenant to
those who adopt Christianity near and
far we are with them
Wow such an evil word there we are with
them verily I the servant that helped us
and my follows defend them because
Christians are my citizens and by Allah
I hold out against anything that
displeases that this leads them counsel
violent oh my gosh yes carry on no
compiled compulsion is to be on them
compulsion in religion did somebody say
compulsion okay neither are there judges
to be removed from their jobs nor the
amongst from the monasteries what's an
oppression neither are no one no one is
to destroy a house of their religion to
damage it or to carry out anything from
it to the Muslims houses okay
should anyone take any of these he was
twelve God's covenant and disobey His
Prophet verily they are my allies and
higher and have my secure charge against
all that they hate this is why we can be
intimate on a carry-on bag
no one is the force them to travel or to
oblige them to fight the Muslims are to
fight for them I repeat the Muslims are
to fight for them if a female question
is married to a Muslim it is a lot to
take place without her approval she is
not to be prevented from this in
visiting her church to pray there clergy
are to be respected they are
is to be prevented from repairing them
nor the sacredness of their covenants no
one of the nation Muslims is to
dissipate the Covenant till the last day
end of the world the chart of the first
periods has been honored and faithfully
applied by Muslims throughout the
centuries in all lands they wrote case
closed
this is and enough evidence night night
all the other things that you're going
to talk about it's all out of context
that's why we have to meet you and
discuss this in person and I can say you
know what forget you mignon must you ask
you man you know you've got more in
common with Isis then we do we are
moving to do right because we condemn
that we condemn the great car and they
are an extremist groups like the KKK do
is lay inclusion for this the wheel a
Christian for that what Hitler did we
blame the Germans for that was the one
world working with is run by movement
bombing Hiroshima Nagasaki millions of
people killed all these affect millions
of people that as a death if you look
into history the amount of claims that's
been done they are not Muslim they are
not woodland the cliched is the slavery
the slave trade were they Muslims know
so let's not have double standards this
is my point
so I'm not going to do that which is I'm
not going to go and have a go at you
nothing you know your absolute mania
you're crazy you're like you are bloody
I see you I'm gonna go for bananas you
are you have mentality behavior I'm
going to do that which is you know what
I'm not going to drop to your level and
do that because our religion doesn't
teach it the Prophet Muhammad peace your
opponent ego attacked his his companions
game with free madness torture they were
kicked out of Medina a little kicks out
of Mecca they went to madness
they were killed they were persecuted
and his he took a stab over attacked but
toward his enemies
yes certain enemies he had mercy the
other ones he tried to kill him of
course he fought them he's not going to
watch their but a lady let me fall some
rules that you guys after you kill me
know it Richard I'm coming to attack you
you have the right to defend yourself
you can't come out big it's uncle Mirza
punch it and you punch me people have
come as they are look at that guy were
terrorists look how technical issues
okay no you have a right to defend
yourself but no way in Islam does it
teach the killing of innocent men
children women animals trees centuries
the Christians Jews
non-muslims Islam says Vista and I
challenge anybody to show me a single
verse in the Quran or the hadith that
alters the killing of innocent people
we're not talking about war when you go
to war of course you're going to what
was interested going to what to go and
have bloody chicken and mushroom time
you know of course you're going for a
reason so that's why which is I really
want to reason with if you are suffering
from mental health issues we look I'm
going to undergo Colombia and you hate
and swear at you in it so I'm not going
to do that which is you some that with
us what we're going to do that with you
because we know better so this is an
advice to me if you want to read the
Quran I'm more than happy to send you a
Quran and more than happy to send you
over on we did and please take this
disgusting video done and which it don't
be a sheep educate yourself the highest
form of ignorance is talking about
something you have no idea about Richard
have you read the Quran with an open
mind not from anti-islamic website have
you done that knowledge and then which
is the highest form of ignorance you
talking about imagine you know nothing
about
can you imagine Richard I go to people
that hate you the usual to ever touch
you to get to know by okay but what we
got to tell me about Richard who is that
this is a no okay
and then I believed it and then I come
and do a level you know what time the
Richard this guy's like this and like
that would that be fair Richard it
wouldn't be fair so why are you doing
the scene to us and our religion you
know it's not that it effects us on
beliefs it doesn't really really doesn't
but it's just sad to see such individual
but your self promotion falling into
this trap of the media the Prophet
Muhammad peace your permit forbade any
kind of animal country a me what you son
which it is use on and looked at these
Western farmers and how these deal with
animals and how cool they are to animals
and you brought that to its clan which
I'm like hold on a second in Islam there
is a method of slaughter now us we can
debate about this animal slow pace when
it falls being cut because we said hey
of course that's what we mean it doesn't
excuse me
when that when the animals and the
animal use sorted as soon as the neck is
cut it binges all conscience and there's
even a study that shows that it is the
most one of the most painless error
message
of sourcing the animal because instantly
book well there's no blood oxygen going
through the brain you black out right so
just because it looks gruesome does not
mean animal suffering and please do not
get is Western form of confusion if not
because it Aslam there is a method that
animal that's going to be sorted should
be it should should be missed away from
the other animal so they do not see it
but animal has to be treated in a kind
manner it has to the eyes have to be
covered so it doesn't see the blade in
case your get scared the Prophet
Mohammed seized upon total this yes the
blade has to be sharp so it doesn't
suffer pain which I talk to you which I
told you about before that yes so in
Islam there is method and this animal
cruelty of kill animal punch animal is
absolutely forbidden in Islam I
challenge you to find me a single
narration of the Prophet Muhammed CC of
Allah in the Quran or his Happy's a
vision in his collection records sayings
that said cruelty to animals instead
there is a narration for the father
Mohammed fish opponent who clearly says
that a a woman who who tied up a cat and
did not feed that cat and stands it to
death entered the Hellfire and a woman
who was a prostitute which is a crime in
X now we believe is a sin who was
walking past the woman sorry dog firstly
about to dies and got her shoes put it
down the well and give that water to the
dog and her sin was forgiven right and
not only that in its time it's forbidden
for you to overburden an animal to hit
an animal to abuse an animal a teacher
from tortas
fear God Almighty in your treatments
towards animals right this is the side
that you don't talk about but Prophet
Muhammad dealt forget physical abuse
psychological abuse towards an animal a
miss in the narration
says we were on a journey and during the
Prophet absence we saw a bird with its
two chicks we took them leaving the
little table children away from the
birth the mother bird was circling above
us in the air beating its wings and
grief when Prophet Mohammed peace upon
him that returned he said to those
individuals who has heard the feelings
of this bird by painting his chicks with
then to her now I can give you many many
many more many more so one thing I do
want to mention is well as that recently
I've been observing you can get a lot of
heat from a lot of youtubers and maybe
the reason why you did this video about
it son just to get that attention out
there and to say hey look guys we've got
a common enemy maybe I don't know right
now
Richard I thought open challenge for you
let's just not be allowed to push their
craft straight to the put Richard we are
challenging you or any other youtuber
who wants to discuss all these months
that is talking about the Prophet
Muhammed Mary ash at nine animal cruelty
killing infidels rarely wherever we find
them some what female rights women's
rights all these things we are more than
happy to discuss them our challenge is
this that first one we meet haven't been
100,000 subscribers the second is that
the wind and the video is we recorded
the debate the discussion is applauded
on your channel as well as mine we will
pay for your ticket
your accommodation your food what is
required for you to attend come to
London
we will across to you and please please
do not use issues of a my life might be
in danger
please seriously seriously but get all
this propaganda or and all this media
rubbish yes I should be more at fear at
coming of meeting news because you are
the one who's been tazed you want to fit
people's for yes and I'm just saying
this I'm going to get on the scene it
yeah I should be more scared yes
so I'm saying I'm more than happy the
challenge is that we will answer all of
your questions every single one the ones
that you are so certain that establish
about rate killing that already stuck we
are more than happy to answer all of
them please do come and let other civil
discussions and let's see it is family
violence does it really teach that let's
find that for itself so we invite you so
thank you guys for watching please
please send this the Ridgid both of you
who knows who he is and his channel
getting this video to him please don't
go in description below I don't know how
to people to go watch it video and see
the ill behavior of him
sorry that's why guys at around
Wellington when I heard somebody better
care to the offense hope you guys
enjoyed this do share with your friends
and families and like I said before as
Muslims we are
our religion religion was impeached
wiser than we are sure you guys and we
are ready to prove that however you like
and that's a challenge so from now on
any issue that comes out and makes us
crave please you say this video to them
goodbye